- [Voiceover] Margo classified
her favorite paintings
hanging in a museum by both
size and dominant color.
The results are in the table above.
We have this table, so
we have dominant color.
We have large size, small size.
We have a bunch of blanks here.
I'm guessing we're going to
have to fill some of these out.
Margo found that, okay
this is interesting,
Margo found that 1/4 of her favorite
large paintings were blue.
How many of Margo's favorite paintings
have red as the dominant color?
So we want to figure out how many
of her favorite paintings,
whether it's large or small,
have red as the dominant color.
So we want to figure out the total number
that have red as the dominant color.
And so to figure this out I
think we're going to have to
figure out some of these other blanks,
and let's start with the information
that they actually gave us.
Margo found that 1/4 of her
favorite large paintings,
so this is her large,
her favorite large paintings.
This right over here
is the total favorite.
This is the total
favorite large paintings.
One-fourth of this, one-fourth of her
favorite large paintings are blue.
So 1/4 of this gives us five.
So 1/4 of what is equal to five?
Or five times four is what?
Well, this needs to be 20.
Five out of 20 is the same thing as 1/4,
and if we know that, then
we can start to fill in
some of these other blanks.
So if we have a total
of 20 large paintings
and five are blue, then 15 are going to
have to be red, because the red large ones
plus the blue large ones
is going to add up to 20.
Now if you have 15 red large
and if you have four red small,
the total number of red is 15 plus four
is 19.
So 19 of Margo's favorite
paintings have red
as the dominant color, 19.